Il y a exactement 10 ans,
j'étais en Afghanistan.
Je couvrais la guerre en Afghanistan,
et j'ai été témoin, en tant que journaliste pour Al Jazeera,
de la souffrance et de la destruction
qui ressortaient d'une guerre comme celle-là.
Ensuite, deux ans plus tard,
j'ai couvert une autre guerre -- la guerre en Irak.
J'étais au milieu de cette guerre
parce que je couvrais la guerre
depuis la partie nord de l'Irak.
La guerre s'est achevée
avec un changement de régime,
comme en Afghanistan.
Ce régime
dont on s'est débarrassé
était en fait une dictature,
un régime autoritaire,
qui, pendant des années,
avait créé un grand sentiment de paralysie
au sein de la nation, et du peuple lui-même.
Cependant,
le changement apporté par l'intervention étrangère
a créé des conditions encore pires pour le peuple
et a accentué le sentiment
de paralysie et d'infériorité
dans cette partie du monde.
Pendant des décennies,
nous avons vécu sous des régimes autoritaires --
dans le monde arabe, au Moyen-Orient.
Ces régimes
ont créé quelque chose en nous pendant cette période.
J'ai 43 ans maintenant.
Pendant les 40 dernières années,
j'ai vu quasiment les mêmes visages
des rois et des présidents qui nous dirigent --
vieux, âgés, autoritaires,
les problèmes de corruption --
les régimes qui nous entourent.
Je me suis demandé pendant un instant,
si nous allions voir de nos yeux
un changement réel s'opérant sur le terrain,
un changement qui ne vient pas d'une intervention étrangère,
de la douleur de l'occupation,
de nations qui envahissent nos terres
et qui parfois accentuent le sentiment d'infériorité.
Les Irakiens : oui, ils se sont débarrassés de Saddam Hussein,
mais quand ils ont vu
leur terre occupée par les forces étrangères,
ils étaient très tristes,
leur dignité en avait souffert.
C'est pourquoi ils se sont révoltés.
C'est pourquoi ils ne se sont pas soumis.
En fait, d'autres régimes ont dit à leurs citoyens :
« Souhaitez-vous qu'il vous arrive la même chose qu'en Irak ?
Souhaitez-vous la guerre civile, les meurtres confessionnels ?
Souhaitez-vous voir la destruction ?
Souhaitez-vous des troupes étrangères sur vos terres ? »
Le peuple a pensé en lui-même :
« Peut-être que nous devrions vivre
dans ce genre de situation autoritaire dans laquelle nous sommes,
au lieu de vivre le second scénario. »
C'était l'un des pires cauchemars que nous ayons vu.
Pendant 10 ans,
nous nous sommes malheureusement retrouvés
à communiquer des images de destruction,
des images de tueries,
de conflits religieux,
des images de violence,
en provenance d'une magnifique parcelle de terre,
une région qui fut jadis la source
des civilisations, de l'art, et de la culture
pendant des milliers d'années.
Je suis ici aujourd'hui pour vous dire
que le futur
auquel nous aspirions
est enfin arrivé.
Une nouvelle génération,
bien instruite,
connectée,
inspirée par des valeurs universelles
et par une compréhension mondiale,
a créé une nouvelle réalité pour nous.
Nous avons trouvé un nouveau moyen
d'exprimer nos sentiments
et d'extérioriser nos rêves.
Ces jeunes gens
qui ont rétabli la confiance
au sein de nos peuples dans cette partie du monde,
qui nous ont donné
un nouveau sens de la liberté
et nous ont transmis le courage pour manifester.
Il ne s'est rien passé. Pas de violence. Rien.
Sortez simplement de chez vous,
élevez la voix,
et dites : « Nous aimerions voir la fin de ce régime. »
C'est ce qui s'est passé en Tunisie.
En quelques jours,
le régime tunisien qui avait investi des milliards de dollars
dans les agences de sécurité,
des milliards de dollars,
pour contenir, essayer de contenir,
ses prisons,
s'est effondré, a disparu,
grâce aux voix du peuple.
Les gens qui étaient inspirés pour manifester
et pour se faire entendre,
on a essayé de les tuer.
Les agences de renseignement voulaient arrêter les gens.
Ils ont trouvé un truc appelé Facebook.
Ils ont trouvé un truc appelé Twitter.
Ils faisaient la distinction entre tous ces problèmes.
Ils disaient :
« Ces enfants sont égarés. »
Par conséquent, ils ont demandé à leurs parents
de descendre dans la rue,
de les récupérer, et de les ramener à la maison.
C'est ce qu'ils demandaient. C'est leur propagande.
« Ramenez ces enfants chez eux,
parce qu'ils se sont égarés. »
Mais oui,
ces jeunes
qui ont été inspirés
par des valeurs universelles,
qui sont suffisamment idéalistes
pour concevoir un magnifique futur,
et qui sont, dans le même temps, suffisamment réalistes
pour équilibrer ce genre d'imagination
et le processus qui y amène --
sans faire usage de la violence,
sans essayer de créer le chaos.
Ces jeunes gens,
ils ne sont pas rentrés chez eux.
Les parents sont en fait descendus dans la rue
et ils les ont soutenus.
C'est comme cela que la révolution est née en Tunisie.
Nous, à Al Jazeera,
nous étions interdits en Tunisie pendant des années,
et le gouvernement interdisait
à tout journaliste d'Al Jazeera de se trouver là-bas.
Mais nous nous sommes aperçus que ces gens dans la rue,
ils étaient tous nos journalistes,
alimentant notre rédaction
d'images, de vidéos,
et d'informations.
Brusquement, cette rédaction à Doha
était devenue un centre destinataire
de toutes ces contributions de ces gens ordinaires --
des gens reliés entre eux et qui ont de l'ambition
et qui se sont libérés eux-mêmes
du sentiment d'infériorité.
Ensuite, nous avons pris cette décision :
nous allons faire défiler les informations.
Nous allons être la voix de ce peuple qui n'en a pas.
Nous allons répandre le message.
Oui, certains de ces jeunes
sont connectés à Internet,
mais la connectivité dans le monde arabe
est très mince, très faible,
à cause des nombreux problèmes qui nous accablent.
Mais Al Jazeera a donné la voix à ces gens
et nous l'avons amplifiée.
Nous l'avons propagée dans tous les salons du monde arabe --
et internationalement, mondialement,
via notre chaîne en Anglais.
Ensuite, les gens ont commencé à ressentir
que quelque chose de nouveau était en train de se produire.
Puis Zine al-Abidine Ben Ali
a décidé de partir.
Ensuite l'Égypte s'y est mise,
et Hosni Mubarak a décidé de partir.
Et maintenant c'est au tour de la Libye.
Puis il y a le Yémen.
Et vous avez beaucoup d'autres pays qui essayent d'apercevoir
et de redécouvrir ce sentiment
du « comment imagine-ton un futur
qui soit magnifique, paisible, et tolérant ? »
Je veux vous dire quelque chose :
Internet et la connectivité
ont créé une nouvelle mentalité.
Mais cette mentalité
continue à être fidèle
au sol et à la terre
desquels elle a émergé.
Alors que c'était la différence majeure
avec les nombreuses tentatives passées
pour créer le changement,
car avant, nous pensions, comme les gouvernements nous le disaient --
et c'était parfois vrai --
que le changement nous était imposé,
et les gens rejetaient cela,
parce qu'ils pensaient que c'était étranger à leur culture,
et toujours, nous avons cru
que le changement naîtrait de l'intérieur,
que le changement devrait être une réconciliation
avec la culture, la diversité culturelle,
avec notre foi en notre tradition
et en notre histoire,
mais dans le même temps,
ouvert aux valeurs universelles, relié au monde,
tolérant au monde extérieur.
C'est ce qui arrive
en ce moment dans le monde arabe.
C'est le bon moment, et c'est en ce moment
que nous voyons ces expressions se rejoindre
et par la suite inaugurer le début
de cette ère magnifique
qui va émerger de cette région.
Comment les élites gèrent-elles cela --
la soit-disante élite politique ?
Face à Facebook,
ils ont amené les chameaux sur la place Tahrir.
Face à Al Jazeera,
ils ont initié le tribalisme.
Ensuite quand ils ont échoué,
ils ont commencé à parler de conspirations
en provenance de Tel Aviv
visant à diviser le monde arabe.
Ils ont commencé à dire à l'Occident :
« Prenez garde à Al-Qaeda.
Al-Qaeda s'empare de nos territoires.
Ce sont des islamistes
essayant de créer de nouveaux Imaras.
Prenez garde à ces gens
qui viennent à vous
pour détruire votre grande civilisation. »
Heureusement,
on ne peut pas duper les gens maintenant.
Parce que cette élite corrompue
dans cette région
a même perdu son pouvoir de duper.
Ils ne pouvaient pas, et ne peuvent pas, imaginer
comment vraiment gérer cette réalité.
Ils ont perdu --
ils se sont détachés
de leur peuple, des masses,
et nous les voyons maintenant s'effondrer
les uns après les autres.
Al Jazeera n'est pas
un instrument de révolution.
Nous ne créons pas de révolutions.
Cependant,
quand un phénomène de cette ampleur survient,
nous sommes au centre de l'information.
Nous étions interdits en Égypte,
et nos correspondants,
certains d'entre eux ont été arrêtés.
Mais la plupart de nos reporters,
et de nos journalistes,
sont passés clandestinement en Égypte -- volontairement --
pour rapporter ce qui arrivait sur la place Tahrir.
Pendant 18 jours,
nos caméras retransmettaient en direct
la voix du peuple sur la place Tahrir.
Je me rappelle un soir
quand quelqu'un m'a appelé sur mon portable --
une personne ordinaire que je ne connaissais pas -- depuis la place Tahrir.
Il m'a dit : « Nous faisons appel à vous
pour ne pas couper les caméras.
Si vous coupez les caméras ce soir,
il y aura un génocide.
Vous nous protégez
en montrant ce qui se passe sur la place Tahrir. »
J'ai ressenti la responsabilité
d'appeler nos correspondants sur place
et d'appeler notre rédaction
pour leur dire : « Faites de votre mieux
pour ne pas couper les caméras cette nuit,
parce que les gars là-bas se sentent vraiment en sécurité
quand quelqu'un retransmet leur histoire --
et ils se sentent également protégés. »
Nous avons donc une chance
de créer un nouveau futur
dans cette région du monde.
Nous avons une chance
d'aller de l'avant et de penser à notre futur
comme à quelque chose d'ouvert sur le monde.
Ne répétons pas les erreurs de l'Iran,
d'une révolution [inaudible].
Libérons-nous -- notamment en Occident --
d'une pensée qui assimile cette partie du monde
aux intérêts pétroliers,
ou aux intérêts
de l'illusion de stabilité et de sécurité.
La stabilité et la sécurité
des régimes autoritaires
ne produisent que
le terrorisme, la violence, et la destruction.
Acceptons le choix du peuple.
Ne choisissons pas et ne décidons pas
qui nous aimerions voir diriger leur futur.
Le futur devrait être dirigé
par le peuple lui-même,
même s'il y a parfois des voix
qui peuvent maintenant nous faire peur.
Mais les valeurs de la démocratie
et le libre-arbitre
qui gagnent le Moyen-Orient en ce moment
sont la meilleure occasion pour le monde,
pour l'Occident et pour l'Orient,
de voir la stabilité et la sécurité
et de voir l'amitié et la tolérance
émerger du monde arabe,
plutôt que les images de violence et de terrorisme.
Soutenons ces peuples.
Supportons-les.
Et abandonnons
notre égoïsme borné
pour accueillir le changement,
et pour célébrer avec les peuples de cette région
un grand futur,
l'espoir, et la tolérance.
Le futur est arrivé,
et le futur, c'est maintenant.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Chris Anderson : J'ai juste deux ou trois questions pour vous.
Merci d'être venu ici.
Comment décrierez-vous la signification historique
de ce qui se passe ?
Est-ce l'évènement de l'année, l'évènement de la décennie,
ou quelque chose de plus ?
Wadah Khanfar : En fait, c'est peut-être bien l'histoire la plus importante de notre vie de journalistes.
Nous avons couvert beaucoup de guerres.
Nous avons couvert beaucoup de tragédies, beaucoup de problèmes,
beaucoup de zones de conflits, beaucoup de points chauds de la région,
parce que nous étions au milieu de tout ça.
Mais c'est une histoire -- c'est une belle histoire ; c'est superbe.
Ce n'est pas un événement que vous couvrez
parce que vous devez couvrir un incident important.
Vous êtes le témoin du changement de l'Histoire.
Vous êtes le témoin de la naissance d'une nouvelle ère.
C'est de ça dont il est question.
CA : Il y a beaucoup de personnes en Occident
qui sont encore sceptiques,
ou qui pensent que ce sera juste une étape intermédiaire
avant un chaos encore plus alarmant.
Croyez-vous vraiment
que s'il y a des élections démocratiques en Égypte maintenant,
un gouvernement puisse voir le jour
qui adopte certaines des valeurs dont vous avez parlé avec tant d'inspiration ?
WK : Les gens, en fait,
après l'effondrement du régime de Hosni Mubarak,
la jeunesse s'est organisée elle-même
en groupes et en associations,
et ils surveillent la transformation,
ils essayent de la mettre sur les bons rails
pour qu'elle satisfasse
aux valeurs démocratiques,
mais dans le même temps,
ils veillent aussi à la rendre raisonnée
et à la rationaliser,
sans laisser le désordre s'installer.
À mon avis, ces gens sont bien plus avisés
que, non seulement l'élite politique,
mais également l'élite intellectuelle, les chefs de l'opposition,
y compris les partis politiques.
À cet instant, la jeunesse dans le monde arabe
est bien plus avisée
et bien plus compétente pour créer le changement
que les anciens --
y compris les vieux régimes
politiques, culturels,
et idéologiques.
(Applaudissements)
CA : Nous n'allons pas nous impliquer politiquement et interférer de cette manière.
Qu'est-ce que les gens ici à TED,
ici en Occident,
devraient faire s'ils veulent s'engager ou faire la différence
et s'ils croient en ce qu'il se passe là-bas ?
WK : Je crois que nous avons découvert un point très important dans le monde arabe --
les gens prêtent attention,
les gens prêtent attention à cette grande transformation.
Mohamed Nanabhay, ici présent,
le directeur de Aljazeera.net,
m'a dit qu'il y avait eu 2500% d'augmentation
du trafic sur notre site Internet
depuis diverses parties du monde.
50% de ce trafic vient d'Amérique.
Parce que nous avons découvert que les gens y prêtent attention
et qu'ils voudraient savoir --
ils reçoivent le flot d'informations via Internet.
Malheureusement, aux États-Unis,
nous ne couvrons que Washington D.C. en ce moment
pour Al Jazeera English.
Mais je peux vous dire que c'est le moment de participer à la fête
en nous mettant en contact
avec ces gens dans les rues
et en leur exprimant notre soutien
et en exprimant ce genre de sentiment universel,
de soutien des faibles et des opprimés
pour créer un futur bien meilleur pour nous tous.
CA : Wadah, des membres de la communauté TED,
à TEDxCairo,
sont rassemblés en ce moment-même.
Ils ont eu plusieurs intervenants là-bas.
Je crois qu'ils ont entendu votre discours.
Merci pour l'inspiration que vous leur donnez et que vous nous donnez à tous.
Un grand merci.
(Applaudissements)